well I ended up hanging out with this
person the other night at Saturday Night
Live and I was like would you ever come
on the show and they were like yes and I
was like oh my God like soon and they
were like yes and guess what they're
here from Studio 8h it's Saturday Night
Live Stars
I mean I'm so happy you're here we
bumped into each other at SNL I found
girled out on you and here we are you
came here yes I did thank you
all right okay we are here at the news
Punky how are you today I'm good I'm
feeling good I'm feeling fresh organic
authentic let's do it blessed
with that good energy will you take our
first story I absolutely will all right
y'all so The Hollywood Reporter says
that Chris Evans AKA Captain America
avoids hosting Saturday Night Live like
the plague and that is a direct quote
huh yeah you say it's terrifying to me
but Drew you've hosted SNL six times and
remained the youngest person to ever
host at just seven yeah
is it terrifying no it's exhilarating
and I think also it's the most tight
running ship on the planet it's about to
be 50 years old wow it is definitely a
um
set it Saturday Night Live is definitely
a different Beast you have to submit to
it to survive you just gotta Be Like
Water you just gotta flow with it and
you'll be just fine that's it be
adjustable so you want a shout out right
now to Chris Evans that he should come
on do a plea listen Chris we know that
you are Captain America and you just
want to wear the American flag and say
let's go but trust me let's go to SNL
you can do it we we want you to come
we'll have a we'll have a ball just
face your fear be brave
well done I love it I love it up next a
reader asked the Washington Post missed
manners about a live performance
etiquette she said that she and her
husband went to a show that was so bad
practically no one was there and then
they wanted to leave early
um and she wanted to go during
intermission but he wanted to leave in
the middle of a song Miss Manor said
quietly bailing at intermission is
definitely less disruptive now of course
you'd never want to offend anybody what
is it like as a stand-up comedian you
have an Insider you know View and
vantage point that other people don't
have
I just you know I mean if you all walk
out walk out gone I don't care I just
you know I'm Gonna Do My Thing
regardless if you were in the seats or
not go on but I put your little church
finger up and excuse yourself just go I
always say though you have to get
everyone together like say you're with a
group of friends I always turn and we're
gonna go I'm like all right ladies let's
get in formation I'm gonna go then count
to 30 then you go count to 60 you go
I'll see you in the lobby we're clean
right beautiful that's the way to do it
yeah I have one thing to say I say this
to my girlfriends all the time when they
ask me questions I said if you are
questioning it and something inside
doesn't feel right you have your answer
and intermission is a much more
appropriate time to do it agreed we
agree with Miss Manners
[Applause]
or up next the New York Post caught up
with a beauty junkie who got her lash
extensions done by a robot what uh Angie
hilum tested the loom Precision last
robot which uses two tweezer-like wands
and binocular lenses to place a full set
of fake eyelashes on you in 50 minutes
oh so you just have a robot in your eye
for 50 minutes and not to worry a
technician stays in the room to oversee
the process just you know in case I
don't know
well I just hope the robot's like yes
Mama you look Fierce
afterwards would you do it so curious
Punky thoughts I don't even want a human
being doing my eyelashes absolutely not
and this one I'll be thinking about the
robot right what if the robot mess up
yeah like how you gonna complain to the
robot he's just gonna be sitting up
there like I cannot compute yeah right
then you ask for the manager the manager
a robot yeah call me old-fashioned but
I'll take a human thank you thank you
thank you all right yes
all right lastly CNN reports that Snoopy
Is Real at least the peanuts pup has a
real-life doppelganger in Bailey a
two-year-old mini shoot doodle who has
gone viral for literally having the same
black eyes and White markings floppy
ears cute button nose as Charlie Brown's
best friend you can even follow him at
Instagram
bailey.sheepadoodle and um it's just
nice to know if you're having a rough
day
just look at Bailey's Instagram and know
that Snoopy is alive and well or you
know if you need something you know what
I need
any pattern of a Woodstock please let me
know because Woodstock was my favorite
character that is
it hunky Johnson Saturday Night Live
returns May 6th with
me
um and musical best Lil Uzi vert um live
on NBC and peacock wait a minute hold on
hold the phone Pete Davidson's coming
back to SNL yep
I feel like Amy polar and Mean Girls
what's the Goss girls like what what is
yeah yeah yeah just a little bit little
tease man y'all just gonna have to tune
in man I'm just trying to write some
music with him hopefully oh hopefully we
don't see so I'm putting it out there
I'm manifesting Petey wheat let's do
something let's write a banger baby okay
he and he write a banger
[Applause]
[Music]